if you do a quick youtube search for
drinking bleach you'll find several
pages of videos on the topic not
surprisingly most of them are meme
related or videos of people supposedly
drinking bleach
according to know your meme yeah I'm
using know your meme as a reference for
a science video the idea of drinking
bleach was thrust into the mainstream in
2012 when a Canadian girl named Amanda
Todd attempted suicide by drinking
bleach due to cyber bullying this made
the phrase a common insult far and wide
over numerous internet communities the
concept of drinking bleach became a meme
and viral hit when youtuber Joey salads
uploaded a prank video in 2015 where he
pretended to drink bleach the stuff is
good and the rest as they say is history
so everyone knows that drink bleach me
but does anyone know what actually
happens when you drink it glad you asked
bleach is a 5 to 8% solution of sodium
hypochlorite dissolved into water and
has a basic pH of 11 the active
ingredient sodium hypochlorite gives it
it's dangerous properties sodium
hypochlorite is a strong oxidizing agent
and is so powerful that it removes the
dye from clothing it's this strong
oxidizing property that makes it
especially corrosive to human tissue
wait a second I've gotten bleach on my
hand before and my skin didn't burn
right that's because the tissue making
up your skin is very different from the
tissue in your mouth your exterior
tissue has multiple layers and is
durable enough to handle abrasion and
mild corrosion the tissue in your mouth
is much different as it's more sensitive
and very thin to allow the secretion of
saliva to break down food unfortunately
a fair amount of cases involving bleach
or caustic ingestion involves children
this is often one of the worst-case
scenarios not just because it involves a
child but also because the damage
affects the physical development of
their body certain tissue were muscles
are damaged and as a result don't
develop properly for example on the
YouTube channel real families an 18
month old boy ingested drain cleaner
he had development issues in his jaw
later in life due to the improper
development from the wounds
after an accident at the tender age of
two healing has been a regular visitor
to temple street for over 12 years
keelin ingested caustic soda when he was
a baby we've been coming to Thompson
Street ever since since 2012 and a half
years were regular visitors and one of
the things that we have noticed is fun
was that there was a significant
restriction of the growth of the Opera
jaw which if it persisted would have
been a major problem for him in the
future and that the surgery was
essentially to remove all the scar
tissue that he had but also to
disconnect the muscles that are around
the jaw and caused the jaw to open and
close all right so you drink the bleach
what happens next well it depends on a
few factors how much you consume how
long was in your mouth and finally where
it went
cases where bleach has a brief exposure
to the mouth and the individual spits it
out immediately has the least damage the
most concerning areas of your mouth are
the tongue tonsils and muscles if these
aren't severely damaged then there is
minor concern as the mouth will heal up
compared to other parts of the
gastrointestinal tract the mouth has the
easiest job it breaks down food
mechanically and then pushes it down
your esophagus pretty simple and durable
on the other hand your stomach and
intestines have to produce acids release
bile salts absorb nutrients and push the
unused contents out of your body a total
distance of 25 feet it's when the bleach
goes beyond the mouth it is partially or
fully swallowed that you have big
problems this is due to the fact that
everything after the mouth is less
durable and has more complex anatomy
for example the esophagus is made of
soft elastic tissue that uses
contractions to push food to the stomach
even minor injuries to the esophagus can
severely damage this process and they
can be lifelong for example on the same
YouTube channel there was a story of a
young girl who consumed bleach she had
only partially swallowed the caustic
solution damaging her upper esophagus
even though the exposure was brief she
had to have her esophagus stretched
every three weeks to allow food to pass
through since her burn Cayla requires
monthly treatment under the guidance of
John Gillick and Owen
Kaela was a five year old girl who
swallowed caustic soda and unfortunately
Kayla mistook this for you know fizzy
drink
Kayla's options at the moment are to
continue to be delayed it's every three
weeks or so so she's looking at a
monthly dilatation so her year if we go
forward like this would be a dilatation
every month or so and the question is
can you cope with this kind of
interference with your life the absolute
worst case scenario is when someone
actually swallows bleach and it travels
down their esophagus into their stomach
the bleach damages the entire length of
the esophagus and most of the stomach
causing maximum damage to the upper GI
tract immediate symptoms include nausea
difficulty swallowing trouble breathing
and shock injuries to both organs are
similar to that of high temperature
burns including blistering hemorrhaging
and even perforation of the tissue this
often results in the organs losing
partial if not all function surprisingly
deaths from intentionally drinking
bleach are uncommon and extremely low
compared to other forms of suicide this
is most likely because the chemical
corrosion of your GI tract is very slow
and extremely painful so people end up
going to the hospital instead of going
through a slow painful death when the
patient arrives at the hospital the
first thing that's addressed is to
breathing the Airways are most likely
inflamed due to inhaling fumes and the
patient won't be able to breathe on
their own breathing has resolved to via
intubation by inserting a breathing tube
through the mouth and down the trachea
if the airway is completely closed where
a tube cannot be passed through a
tracheostomy is performed instead an
incision is made in the trachea itself
and a tube is then placed through the
opening to allow oxygen into the lungs
next the stomach is diluted with water
or milk and pumped of any remaining
bleach and then damage is assessed the
corrosive burns result in extensive
scarring that causes even more problems
later on when the body repairs severe
tissue damage
it doesn't just form regular scars like
those from a small cut it has to rebuild
the upper and lower layers of the skin
called the epidermis and dermis the
deeper the wound the more extensive the
body repairs it it does this by laying
down layers of fibrous protein called
collagen
when it adds multiple layers the
appearance becomes that of scar tissue
scar tissue is very rigid and thick and
although it does rebuild the tissue one
downside is it reduces elasticity this
is not a problem on the surface of your
skin but detrimental to the esophagus
and stomach which requires stretching to
allow the food to pass through the same
issue happened to the young girl who
drank bleach her esophagus was not
permitting food to pass through due to
the stiffness from the formation of scar
tissue once you damage your esophagus
our hero that you really can't can't
repair us we would hope that the
dilatations would become less necessary
and to make on the stage when we can
actually physically stop them now if we
can't kate is looking at a much bigger
procedure and her parents know that we
were planning on once that if we could
keep it open and keep it off and sooner
or later it might give up for them just
unstable from but it's 18 months down
the road no it hasn't
[Applause]
alright Johnny now let's tell her
patient what his options are well behind
door number one he can wait for an organ
donation which is it much of an option
folks because he's not just waiting for
one but two different organs and it
could be months two years before
receiving them behind door number two he
can receive a very delicate surgical
procedure called and the soffit ejected
me and colon into position thanks for
playing
what happens when you drink bleach
normally in an esophageal part of the
esophagus is removed and the stomach is
made into a new esophagus however in
this case both organs are severely
damaged so in a South ejecting me and
colon into position is done instead in
the procedure the esophagus and stomach
are removed from the body your large
intestine is cut from its position
routed around your breastbone and
attached to the opening of your throat
functioning as a substitute esophagus
and stomach and esophagus me and colon
interposition is a delicate procedure in
comes with the risk of infection and
leaking of ingested contents or bodily
fluids however in one study following
692 patients who receive the procedure
only eight point eight percent had signs
of organ leakage so there's that also
with the large intestine being routed
around the breastbone there is a
noticeable bulge of intestine in the
patient's chest the upside of all this
is the procedure has a very high success
rate and allows the patient to return to
a mostly normal life I say mostly normal
because your stomach is gone normally
what the stomach the food is broken down
with acid churned and then sent to the
intestines for absorption with the
stomach now gone these two steps are
skips and any food that is eaten will
not be properly absorbed due to lack of
proper digestion instead your diet will
have to be changed to a liquid diet of
soup or eating predigested food most
likely in a liquid or smoothie form so
it can be properly absorbed so if you
need any reason not to drink bleach just
think of a very slow and painful death
organ leakage intestinal bulge in your
chest and drinking a hamburger for lunch
thanks for watching and click the bell
to subscribe you know
[Music]
you
you